foreign
for everybody's favorite segment facts
are your friends
cue the Camaro music
our personality tests accurate
our online mental health assessments
worth the zeros and ones they are
printed on the internets
oh boy all right so
get your
um
I don't believe you get them all ready
because here we go
can you trust personality tests is the
name of this article from psychology
psychology today our personality tests
accurate from Psychology today
betterhelp.com personality test accuracy
and practical uses on and on and on and
on there are a million of them
Myers-Briggs let's see here the disc
assessment Winslow hexaco big five
little five there's not little five but
um
there's also I'm gonna lump these all
into a bucket here there's also
you used to maybe say this way it used
to be the DSM the diagnostic and
statistical manual
the manual that medical practitioners
and mental health practitioners use to
make mental health diagnosis it's a it's
a big medical book
it's got diagnostic codes in it it's got
all this medical language and jargon it
used to be like when I was in grad
school we had to spend I don't know
there's a couple hundred bucks I think
to get to get it and you have to learn
how to read it and you got to learn how
to use it now it's just on the internet
everybody so there's there's no context
anymore everything's stripped of context
and it's just Googling do I have ADHD
and here's a 10 question quiz on
Facebook or do I have borderline
personality disorder and comorbid
anxiety and major depressive disorder
and I'm just gonna google it and then
there's these tests you can take online
while you're on the toilet and it will
just tell you like oh
I got um
post-traumatic stress disorder
or I've got
an agoraphobia whatever the thing is
so
here's my thoughts on these and we've
talked about them a little bit um in the
past and so I want to be pretty clear
about it here's some things uh let me
look at some of these things we printed
off here
um a 2018 article in Scientific American
offered a harsh review of Myers-Briggs
and other personality tests
essentially they're saying there is zero
signs to back them up none
none
some have come back and said well I mean
that article was a little bit harsh
there's some stuff there's some utility
there it there is some good information
out there
um there's no study saying that they're
not great
uh
another
here's I'm gonna I'm just gonna take a
quick left turn here
I can go through all these but I think
I'm Gonna Save Us a whole bunch of time
here's the deal on personality tests
on online mental health diagnostic tools
number one they can be fun
it can be fun
when I have my magical time and I'm late
for the 17th time that day for something
it can be fun to ask myself what is
wrong with me into Google do I have ADHD
and to take a 10 question thing
or maybe by now they maybe even uploaded
some of the uh clinical assessments
cool that can be fun
they can also give a baseline for
conversation so I can go to my therapist
and say hey I took this 10 question
thing it said I scored a 10 out of 10 on
ADHD
I would love to find out if this is what
I have and I learned love to learn about
ADHD and then more importantly learn
how I can live my life based on this
on this new insight great cool
they should not be used in any sort of
concrete predictive way
same with personality tests I'm an ENFP
or an istj or whatever the thing is cool
it's a self-reporting tool it's the way
you think you show up in the world and
by the way every time I've given one of
those every time I've taken one I mean
every time I've taken one of those
strengths whatever the thing is people
around me always say John no you don't
you do it like this
and I think man I came on I come on
really hard when I answer questions I'm
harsh and they'll say like
the nicest guy I know or I'll say like
I'm like the nicest guy I know and
they're like uh you're kind of the worst
right other people other people are
often infinitely more reflective about
how you show up in the world because
they experience you
and so
they can be fun but they shouldn't be
used in some predictive way you should
not hire somebody because they have the
wrong letters from an internet test
you shouldn't fire somebody because they
have the wrong letters from the internet
test
that's poor management it's poor
leadership
you should not marry somebody because of
the wrong Enneagram number
you shouldn't not marry somebody because
they have different big fives than you
do or a different love language than you
do
don't use these for diagnostic tools
only use them for reflection
for looking in the mirror and going huh
it feels like it Nails me
feels like it sums it up
that's a good thing in our culture we
are terrible about being reflective
we're so concerned with how other people
make us feel we're so in concerned with
our latest outrage the the latest thing
we are
um
you know offended by
the way I was having this conversation
this weekend with a friend
in the new attention economy so let's
say 150 years ago you're the town crier
you had the kid that came out on the
corner you know with the newspaper
saying hear ye hear ye here's what's
going on in the world
and you had to get up and go see what
was going on you had to bring your
attention to the info
now there news is everywhere it's just
pumped into your head 24 7 365 it's on
every screen and I'm beginning to wonder
if the the way I counteract in the past
the way I counteracted the world the way
I handled the world is by getting the
information now
the way I protect myself
is to walk away
in an attention economy the greatest way
I can hurt somebody's business isn't to
comment on everything and to stamp and
scream and yeah it's to walk away
just to walk away
but that's about being reflective how do
you show up how do you answer how do you
feel when you how do you experience the
world cool these things are good for
that they're good to discuss with
friends and colleagues uh to get some
ideas on how you might be viewing
yourself incorrectly or on how you can
double down on the things that you're
good at that's awesome that's very good
it's very good I never understood I was
uh one of the strings quests was a
maximizer
until until I took that thing
and it said you're a maximizer you look
at somebody's idea and you say man this
could be this
I never thought of that that was right
I do feel that way a lot that doesn't
mean I don't have my own ideas that
doesn't mean my maximization is always
correct that doesn't mean I have
permission to be late to everything the
number of times I especially when like
strings Quest first came out and I would
have an employee and be like hey you've
been late five days in a row like hey
sorry bro I'm a maximizer I gotta wait
till the good ideas are there and then I
no you gotta be on time
gotta be on time
so let me say this
profoundly and boldly never diagnose
yourself from the internet ever ever
ever ever always see a professional
medical or mental health practitioner
full stop end of story
don't don't don't get on the internet at
2 A.M when you can't sleep and start
googling because you're gonna figure out
you've got 40 different Diagnostics
40 different quote unquote mental health
issues which don't even like that word
in addition to training professionals
have wisdom
we've seen lots and lots of other people
if you go back and listen to this show
over the last couple of years the one
thing I love to bring to people
is social norming you're not crazy
there's a whole bunch of people
experiencing the world just like you
you're not broke and your body's just
trying to take care of you
so a mental health practitioner can
contextualize something you may feel
like you are out of control they'll look
at you and go you're good you're good I
asked one of the guys who trained me
recently he was in town Nashville Dr
Young and we had dinner
and I said hey is like once and for all
I trust trust him is oppositional
defined disorder is that real I I hear
data on one side I hear conversations
with practitioners on the other side
here's what he said he said yep it's
real and you've never seen it
so what do you mean I've never seen it
I've seen fifth graders and
five-year-olds losing their mind
he said until you've been in a psych
ward and there's six grown men unable to
hold down a seven-year-old
who's literally able to pull a door off
of its hinge like
it's real you probably never seen it
that's the difference between or go to
work when you do uh your your mental
health
um degree in your mental health graduate
degree and you go do some time in uh
a psychiatric hospital or a
you know mental health ward
oh
that's what major depression looks like
there's context there
don't go to the internet
okay
we used to know who we were in
relationship to others
one of the most Brilliant Minds I think
is a guy named Andrew Peterson he's a
songwriter and author he says your
community defines your calling
your community the people you love and
interact with and talk to and experience
every day will tell you
man you you're not going to want a job
where all you do is budgets sitting at a
table all day you're gonna go crazy
you don't need some
some faceless mindless computer program
to tell you what your personality is
ask the people around you
ask your friends and if you don't have
those people let this be a sign go get
those people in your life
find a mentor that will tell you dude I
I think your strengths are this let's
discuss that let's have these
conversations real people and real
friends
so
have fun with personality exams or
personality tests have fun with them
get online and see with one of these
internet quizzes if you might have
generalized anxiety disorder cool
ask a friend
and then go see a professional
go talk to somebody with training and
expertise in wisdom and context
that's the path to getting well
not trying to solve this with the
internet